...
-J'étais cool, assis sur un banc,
c'était au printemps.
Ils cueillent une marguerite,
ce sont deux amants.
Overdose de douceur,
ils jouent comme des enfants.
Je t'aime un peu, beaucoup,
à la folie, passionnément.
Mais à la suite d'une douloureuse
déception sentimentale,
d'humeur chaleureuse,
je devenais brutal.
La haine d'un être n'est pas dans
nos prérogatives, Tchernobyl,
tcherno-débile !
Jalousie radio-active.
Caroline était une amie,
une superbe fille.
Je repense à elle,
à nos cornets vanille,
à sa boulimie de fraises,
de framboises, de myrtilles,
à ses délires futiles,
à son style pacotille.
Je suis l'as de trèfle
qui pique ton coeur.
L'as de trèfle qui pique ton coeur.
L'as de trèfle
qui pique ton coeur, Caroline.
...
Comme le trèfle à quatre feuilles,
je cherche votre bonheur.
Je suis l'homme qui tombe à pic
pour prendre ton coeur.
Il faut se tenir à carreau,
Caro, ce message vient du coeur.
Une pyramide de baisers,
une tempête d'amitié.
Une vague de caresse,
un cyclone de douceur.
Un océan de pensées.
Caroline, je t'ai offert
un building de tendresse.
J'ai eu une peur bleue,
je suis poursuivi par l'armée rouge.
Pour toi j'ai pris des billets
verts, il a fallu que je bouge.
Pyromane de ton coeur,
canadair de tes frayeurs.
Je t'ai offert
une symphonie de couleurs.
Elle est partie, maso,
avec un vieux macho
qu'elle a rencontré dans un métro.
Quand je les vois main dans la main
fumant le même mégot,
je sens un pincement dans son coeur,
mais elle n'ose dire un mot.
Je suis l'as de trèfle
qui pique ton coeur.
L'as de trèfle qui pique ton coeur.
L'as de trèfle qui pique ton coeur,
Caroline.
Claude MC prend le microphone
genre love story raggamuffin
pour te parler d'une amie
qu'on appelle Caroline.
Elle était ma dame, ma came,
ma vitamine,
ma drogue, ma dope, ma coke...
Mon amphétamine, Caroline.
...
Je repense à elle, femme actuelle,
20 ans, jeune et jolie.
Remets le film à l'envers,
magnéto de la vie.
Pour elle, faut-il l'admettre,
des larmes ont coulé.
Hémorragie oculaire, vive notre
amitié. Du passé, du présent,
je l'espère du futur. Je suis passé
pour être dans ton futur.
La vie est un jeu de cartes,
Paris, un casino.
Je joue les rouges coeur,
Caro.
...
Je suis l'as de trèfle
qui pique ton coeur, Caro.
L'as de trèfle qui pique ton coeur.
L'as de trèfle
qui pique ton coeur, Caroline.
Je suis l'as de trèfle
qui pique ton coeur.
L'as de trèfle qui pique ton coeur.
L'as de trèfle
qui pique ton coeur, Caroline.